all right moving on to politics here new
york's democratic governor andrew cuomo
faces calls to resign
after a second former aide accused him
of sexual harassment the woman claims
cuomo repeatedly asked her questions
about her sex life while she worked for
him last year
cuomo for his part says he never
intended to offend anyone or
cause any harm our national
correspondent jerica duncan is following
this story for us drika good morning to
you
good morning the governor says he is
handing over this investigation to the
state attorney
general after she denied his original
request to choose a private investigator
now the ag is expected to have full
investigative authority and even
oversee a law firm that will have the
power
to subpoena charlotte bennett laid out
allegations of harassment against
governor andrew cuomo in the new york
times
events that she says took place over
several months
in one encounter last june bennett said
cuomo asked if she was romantically
involved
whether she was monogamous in her
relationships and if she had ever had
sex with older men
the 25 year old former executive
assistant added
i understood that the governor wanted to
sleep with me
and felt horribly uncomfortable and
scared yesterday the governor apologized
writing
i now understand that my interactions
may have been insensitive
or too personal some of the things i
have said have been misinterpreted as an
unwanted flirtation
to the extent anyone felt that way i am
truly
sorry alessandra biaggi is chair of the
state
senate's ethics committee and worked in
the governor's office in 2017.
he's actually saying that he meant for
those words to be playful and
there is no realm of playful
when a governor of a state asks a young
staffer who is 25 years old
if she has sex with older men or if she
has sex outside of her relationship
that is not only inappropriate
it is abusive the allegations have led
to swift calls for an investigation from
many prominent democrats
including president joe biden president
biden has been consistent that he
believes that
every woman should be heard should be
treated with respect and with dignity
new york attorney general leticia james
will lead that investigation into
bennett's claims
and those of another former aide lindsey
boylan
in a post last week boylan alleged cuomo
once kissed her on the mouth
without permission cuomo has denied all
of boylan's claims
that behavior from the governor is the
exact behavior that prevents us from
having good governance
it impacts policy the lack of just being
able to acknowledge that either mistakes
are made or that certain behavior is
harmful to others
is highly problematic of someone who
holds the office that is the
highest office of the state of new york
state senator biaggi says that in the
past governors have had a lot of power
when it comes to investigations within
the state
she says she's hopeful that the attorney
general's involvement in this case
will lead to more transparency anthony
jerica thank you